نبدا نشرتنا باخر التطورات الميدانيه في
السودان حيث افاد مراسلنا بسماع دوي
انفجار في منطقه الجريف الشرقيه الخرطوم
مع استمرار تحليق طائرات وسماع اصوات
مضادات ارضيه كما سمعت اصوات انفجارات
تدوي وسط العاصمه وشرقي الخرطوم بحري
وفي التطورات ايضا قال الجيش السوداني ان
المتمردين اجمل مهندسين على تعطيل محطات
التحكم للكهرباء والمياه ما ادى
الانقطاعها عن مناطق واسعه في البلاد حسب
بيان الجيش من جانبها قالت قوات الدعم
السريع في بيان انها تعمل على استعاده
خدمه الكهرباء في عدد من ولايات ومدن وشرق
ووسط السودان بمعاونه مهندسين فنيين
واضافت انها تواصل العمل مع فريق هندسي
كبير لاصلاح الخلل في محطه مياه بحري لكن
من وصفتهم بالانقلابيين اطلاق النار على
المحطه للحول دون وصول الفريق الهندسي
وقالت انها تعمل على ايجاد حلول للمشكله
في الاثناء استانفت حركه المواصلات
الداخليه في الخرطوم نشاطها بعد مرور اكثر
من عشرين يوما على المواجهات العسكريه بين
الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع ورصد
مراسل الجزيره حركه للسيارات العامه في
ضاحيه الاتحاد باندرمان غربيه الخرطوم وفي
الجريف شرق شرقيه الخرطوم كما تمكنت بعض
الاسر من التنقل في احياء العاصمه بعد
توقف لعده ايام بسبب الاشتباكات